How Many Burgers Come from One Cow? ...and
8 other food facts.
1.
Other than the color of the shell, there is
no difference between commercial brown shelled
chicken eggs and a white shelled ones.
Non-commercial eggs from chickens may taste
slightly different, due to difference in diet,
but a chicken that lays white eggs will produce
an egg that is by taste and nutrition the
same as the eggs produced by a chicken that
lays brown eggs with the same diet.
(QF: 585)
2.
An average beef cow (200 kg of usable meat)
produces enough meat to make about 4,500 hamburgers
at McDonalds.
(QF: 482)
3.
About 3 billion pounds of potatoes are used
to make McDonald’s fries every year.
This is about 8% of all potatoes grown in
the United States or a half a percent of all
potatoes grown in the world per year.
(QF: 479)
4.
Common foods that are naturally radioactive
include potatoes, bananas, sunflower seeds,
Brazil nuts, and kidney beans, among others.
Brazil nuts are the most radioactive by far
at 6600 picocuries per kg or about 1.875 BED
(banana equivalent dose).
The radium in Brazil nuts does not come from
especially high levels of radium in the soil
where the trees grow, but rather the very
extensive root systems the trees develop,
which cover a much larger area of the soil
than most trees.
5.
The most expensive coffee is coffee where
the berries go through the digestive tract
of the Kopi Luwak (a small cat-sized Indonesian
animal).
The “beans” are then harvested from the
animal’s waste, cleaned, roasted, and sold.
This coffee costs $100 to $600 per pound.
Just like when you buy food, in the end, you
are essentially paying for poop.
6.
Archeological evidence suggests that the earliest
known purposefully fermented drink, specifically
beer, was made all the way back in the late
Stone Age around 10,000 BC, also making it
one of the earliest known prepared food substance
along with bread, which dates back to around
the same time.
The earliest references to wine being made
are found in Egypt around 4000 BC.
7.
The now common “Fish and Chips” combo
originated in Britain around 1860.
For nearly 200 years before that, fish vendors
had been serving fried fish on the streets
of Britain.
Sometime around the mid-19th century, one
of them got the bright idea to serve thick
cut French fries with the fried fish, with
the first known “Fish and Chip” eatery
opened by Joseph Malin in 1860.
After this, the popular combo rapidly spread
throughout Britain and the world.
8.
Grapes explode when microwaved.
(QF 503)
9.
Mao Sugiyama from Japan had his testicles
and penis removed when he was 22 and served
them to dinner guests at $250 per plate, with
a total of 6 plates.
(QF 545)